تخطط الطائرة للهبوط على الشاطئ،
وهذا ليس خطأ،
لدينا فحص شاطئي لكل
طائرة تهبط ونقوم
بدوريات أمنية للتأكد من عدم تجول أي شخص
في مدارجها،
لأنه المطار الوحيد في العالم
الذي لديه طائرة تهبط عليه جدول زمني
الشاطئ
أنا هنا في مطار جلاسكو الدولي،
يوم منسم قليلاً اليوم
وسننقلك إلى باريت بعد ظهر هذا اليوم
[موسيقى]
من فضلك [
موسيقى] وبالتالي
مجانًا، أنت واضح
للكاثوليكي، يجب أن نتوقع القليل
من السحب ربما  بعض زخات المطر على
الطريق والرياح في بارا تبدو وكأنها تسير
مباشرة على المدرج، لذلك هذا
جيد جدًا
[موسيقى]
ولكنه جميل،
فالبارا الزرقاء خضراء وذهبية باريس
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير ولكن معلومات يمكنني مساعدتك يا
جيمي، كيف حالك؟  أنت المطار
حيوي بالنسبة لك، فهو
مصنف على أنه خدمة شريان الحياة، إنها
عملية صغيرة لدينا 11
موظفًا أعمل
كخدمة عملاء أمنية وأعمل أيضًا في
البرج
يتم تحديد أوقات التشغيل لدينا من خلال
المد والجزر، ويمكن أن يكون لدينا أربعة مواسم في
واحد  من الأفضل أن يتحدث الآخرون
عن جايلز ونعتقد أن هذا مجرد
نسيم
نميل إلى الاتصال بـ Bar على بعد حوالي 20
إلى 30 ميلًا قبل أن نصل فعليًا إلى
روجر،
كان علينا العودة من باريت
بسبب سوء الأحوال الجوية في الشتاء أكثر من
في الصيف ولكن يمكن أن يحدث ذلك في أي
وقت من السنة
[موسيقى]
عندما تصل الطائرات إلى
ترددنا انظر إليهم،
فحص الشاطئ حيث يوجد المد والجزر والتحديثات
بالطريقة التي تسير على طول الطريق حتى
يعرفوا ما سيأتي
ونطلب منهم الهبوط وفقًا لتقديرهم، لقد
كان ذلك عنصرًا من عناصر التركيز مع
اقترابنا قليلاً لأنه لا يوجد
طيار آلي على الإطلاق، كل ذلك يدوي
لذا عليك استخدام عينيك
وتقييم مساحة الفحص النهائية، الشيء
الرائع حقًا في هذا  المهمة هي أن
لدينا الفرصة لممارسة هذه
المهارة بشكل صحيح،
لا يوجد توجيه للهبوط، لذا إذا
كنتم تضيءون وكلاكما
يعتني ببعضكما البعض
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
شكرًا لك
[موسيقى]